hello there Reid technician I'm Greg
Alba my he's 80 when he leads a Nikko
check out her YouTube channel where she
does reactions with her hubby dusty oh
my god that just sounds so good
Bobby dusty this came out a couple days
ago Avengers a day prologue gameplay
footage repeat yes you see it I remember
watching that trailer and I had some of
my like for the most part I'm pretty
excited about the games I really do love
spider-man PS yes but you know I was
like a little bit questionable about
some of the graphics but at the end of
the day I'm like cutscenes aside I just
want to see what the gameplay is like
yeah didn't give us any of that would
see some people were saying some of that
was gameplay wait really
I thought it wasn't yeah so let's check
this out let's see what they got our
moving wrong right now let's make this
happen
[Music]
recorded directly from you know exactly
what that mean sir
square enix
never meet your heroes haha I've seen
the boys
yeah I'm not a fan I thought it's fine
[Music]
cuz they can fly there we go this is the
gameplay right here yeah spy beam Nixon
yeah
Oh
[Music]
okay oh nice look at his biceps Odin son
damn Oh are the combos no he's doing it
for humans they can really handle this
handsome combat nice I love ya
[Music]
nice to these people gotta be dead right
yeah something's gonna happen to that
bus
[Music]
[Music]
dude Wow I'm surprised some of these
people can handle right not like one day
one oh no these guys have shields
[Music]
with your shield whoa you laughed about
it what in the world that house you see
all the little mini tornado yeah it's
tire man
[Music]
Oh
let's irrigate
I would chose what the trimmer now this
is like fly yeah now we know he's got
more of this of course this is just so
you can get to this section what Wow
just murdered a bunch of civilians over
there
no captain backer
yeah
Oh
they've got Martinez
destroy everything I wanted to be like
Joe comment send him Black Widow she'll
save the day you're up
it's the Hulk come on
it's time to go green I don't like a
[Music]
oh my god he's massive objective oh my
god you are murdering them but there's
bad guys oh so much for Heroes he's my
favorite I was really the storm and they
gave us the home oh man oh my gosh look
at that duties its face angry
[Music]
go go
[Music]
you
I feel like there's more detail put into
the home yeah look at him Oh No
I like it when you pick somebody up or
just measure this is bloody mature
rating
I could watch this game play all day
just the whole just the whole entire
game
the way he's hopping from building to
building reminds me oh boy yeah you like
jump getting there I'm getting there
you try doing this oh he likes under
clap them I don't even know that's why
he does it and uh the whole movie never
Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
nice dear folks is the day is my
favorite amazing hey those weapons were
meant for the good guys is that supposed
to be a joke not the time get your heads
in the game sure not seems like the
reactors malfunctioning not getting
strange readings on the monitors like
we're being pulled away heat signal well
get it
that is going to destroy the - I'm
having trouble
do you read boots a catheter
that's cool that's cool eventually did
you what's kind of cool is he's got like
long range and you can also get you know
getting close like you guys to take cats
in Americus he's a love cookies alone we
can take them
whoa dude crossbow grab those you know I
know it probably has nothing to do with
a movie but yeah boom oh man I love the
attention to calm the details with like
their weapons yeah
[Music]
everyone gets a move where they hit the
ground
[Music]
you comfortable leaning like that sure
into it she's got a Captain Marvel
single ayah she told you say those years
ago
[Music]
what's gonna happen she said what you
said
yeah whispered it cuz I love song I was
like that's taskmaster I like it when
his live eyes light up
[Music]
oh wow
oh here we go I've been wanting to see
hers just to see what she can do think
they'll give her like an explosion like
she hits the ground crowd out
Wow these are the best the graphics of
look
yeah
you know you were the father that's just
guns damn taskmaster here ask you to
really take some hits Oh sounds painful
you got to get the ScarJo booty show
nice huh the trash-talking tape
Wow like what a movie like that oh yeah
yeah I mean you gotta have the scissor
for little back handsprings come on
taskmaster do something worthy of a
challenge make this seem like an
obstacle
[Music]
frustrating always one step behind it's
a little slower than the other ones
because she's you know straight up and
again they seem to take some pauses but
what she wants yes that's her exploding
move that's bachelor sounds like some
angry white college
whoa did she just go stealth move that's
very cool
well that's like the ultimate advantage
can't see me
eyes oh dude there it is whoa it's like
a Mortal Kombat
[Music]
nice sounds gonna go wrong you think
you've won around Rome enough the world
will remember this day contain their
heroes failed them that's what I would
do
sure
here
he's collapsing Wow
Steve can you hear me get the hell out
of there that was the ultimate
distraction plan yeah
[Music]
[Music]
who some say they were set up others
call them murderers do the Avengers pose
a danger to society that was the
question Bruce that was the question is
that why not dead guy no but that's not
how this story ends
oh whoa
okay may next year
well I definitely liked it more than the
first one that you saw yeah I agree with
that I can I mean man like the Hulk was
the coolest part he is probably the one
that like everybody want to play so good
which is it's something out the person
it's like thrashing them around like if
you're really mad and you want to hurt
someone he picked up that giant chunk of
like the ground he's just like oh you
know what's funny is like poke is not my
favorite character in Marvel but he's my
favorite character here
Iron Man tends to be a fan favorite and
you meet the least impact for me in this
one yeah I mean he kind of just seemed
like a lesser I mean I know he could
some sooner Iron Man stuff but in some
ways it seemed like different variations
of what Thor could do ya know it's like
Thor had the Lightning and everything
and I love it I love the use of the meal
I always say no I would say meal nor
mule Nia no mere meal near me the use of
meal near I think was really cool like
the attention to detail it's similar of
a cap would have like the boomerang
nobility with it but his is a little bit
more specific I'm like locking on to one
target yeah it just seems like you know
that hammer would be murdering the [ __ ]
out of everyone who's there right I'll
be Ted but also recap shield - it's
different than me on there because it
can hit multiple people at once
and I love that detail like especially
we can jump up and kick it I really feel
like the game developers thought about
alright so what are like there's special
unique abilities that they're known for
and how can we really enhance or utilize
those ways that we've seen done in the
movies in the comics but also that we
haven't seen done yet and I feel like
for the most part they brought that to
life I'd say I would agree I think the
one that I probably was I want to say
the least impressed with but I don't
know if they're just kind of holding
back a little bit because the game's not
out but Iron Man I think I was least
excited out of all of them what's good
for the kid that was just flying for a
long time we're gonna get it I was the
objective of that yeah yeah I get it
like Natasha had the boss fight with the
taskmaster so I get it but I think it's
kind of hard to be compared to like the
gameplay for Hulk and Thor and even
Captain America those are really great
this Black Widow stood out to me though
yeah I love
variation of weapons that she had and my
the stealth mode was a nice surprise -
we've definitely haven't seen her pulled
that off I wonder if you know having
taskmaster featured in this prologue
trailers in the game in general might
entice some people to go and check this
game out because of the black widow
movie coming out mask masters one of the
main villains in that movie or is the
main villain so I think that's a cool
little tie-in yeah I'm definitely still
not as compelled for this game as I was
hoping I would be yeah because
occasionally I don't know how much crap
I'm gonna get for this because as much
the Internet so you never know you never
know or you really do know and you say
it anyway
yeah I feel like the game looks like a
lot of fun and I feel like for the most
part in terms of gameplay they've really
thought this through
there are times with the voice-over
within the cutscenes and with the
graphics that I feel like I'm watching a
great mobile app game if that makes
where it is like it looks a little aged
to me that's I mean by mobile the
problem is that and I'm not saying it's
poorly done it certainly isn't that
because the gameplay was very intricate
and they really took the time to kind of
make sure the battle is between the
heroes and the baddies like it looked
good and everybody had their own shiny
moments and it kind of stood out and you
can kind of find the character you're
most likely to play with by watching
that video and like I know I'm probably
gonna pick the war or Hulk my problem is
that fine if they don't look like the
movie characters I don't need that but
it just looked aged and especially
nowadays we're getting very realistic
gameplay from all these games and you
come out with this for the ps4 you just
kind of like well yeah and there's also
the attention of like it's Marvel like
an Avengers ps4 game the Spider Man ps4
game just nailed it it's so good on
every like every way you could think of
they nailed it even even like banter
amidst fights kind of like what we were
watching here I don't really know what I
could really ask for other than just you
know better graphics I feel like if the
graphics were a little bit better from
time to time yeah maybe the voice work
would also stand out a little bit more
it just didn't seem to mesh together
yeah there's something about it you
still feel very bad yeah
I felt very separate for some reason
like like when Natasha or any of the
character was speaking I don't know
something
come together there's something about it
it doesn't feel so lived in and I don't
know what it I can't quite pinpoint its
problem sometimes when you do reactions
I can't quite
I had the perfect sentence I could that
is one of the issues where you're
talking about those I feel like a lot of
puzzle pieces I see what they're going
for it ice I feel out or they're gonna
for I'm sure as I pick it up and play it
it's just you know it's to get on board
for an adventure like this I'm gonna
want to feel like really hooked into the
storyline and everything but also to be
hooked into the storyline where there's
cutscenes and stuff you do need to have
the gameplay itself really be you know
super anti CG and this is the just the
prologue version and similar to Spider
Man when you're in the prologue of that
game you know it's a Spider Man handling
business kicking ass not really a bunch
of obstacles you have to overcome this
is Congo free games to do this where
they release like the first 20 minutes a
game played or something but I would
want to see something of you know when
is it a real obstacle for them what do
any of these guys have you know I wonder
if because as an Avenger so it's
different team members different
abilities if you can't just be that one
character throughout you they will make
you play however it serves the story
it's like for this part of the story you
have to be Black Widow in order to move
forward yeah so that that could maybe
post challenges you know to keep things
fresh with I hope so with the gamers -
yeah because with spider-man they do
that like sometimes you're Miles Morales
sometimes you're Mary Jane Watson
sometimes you're spider-man that's the
vibe I got here is that the game's gonna
be like okay now you're this person and
I gotta do this person yeah cool it's
fun
yeah the gameplay is great I have fun
watching it that's probably the final
question I have is is this the game I
will actually commit to finishing till
the end what question you've been in a
halfway through where I'm just like yeah
let's all repeat yeah so but if the
story lines great and compelling I am a
little curious to see what happens like
how do they find cap yeah you can't just
make him disappear when he's like a
playable characters sorry it happened
sound like the last 10 God did you know
you
yeah frozen under the ice for like a
long time and wait he goes down with a
[ __ ] but he's dead nah he ain't
impossible he's got one more thing is I
get a little bit distracted when I'm
seeing them fight sometimes with human
characters because I'm so well aware of
the movies
yeah like when he's using the hammer
he'd be dead he's murdering these people
totally like let's go again really how
they stay yeah they stand up so I get
distracted by having that preconceived
notion in my hands they do it anyway
guys I'm excited for the game still
alive I'll definitely at least go to a
friend's place and try it out for a
couple hours you know but I haven't
cheated on buying it yet penny who are
you guys excited for the game though let
us know your thoughts down below well
those are your thoughts about us too
that's what I really want to read
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell checkout Wendy's
channel the movie couple Channel it's
awesome I'm subscribed you should
subscribe to and I would let you have a
page in the day shout to a man who I
love and adore Wendy I don't know think
I've told you about him is not as Tyler
Hague he lives in Wisconsin we have
sometimes Google hangout hung out with
him sure that's the way to say I don't
mean to brag but oh yeah he got me a ps4
last year stop it I mean I sent him a
nude photos ah
he asked for the ps4 back I said no no
no this is the exchange he's like I was
just being kind i needa didn't have one
I love you and John the whole channel so
I gave you a ps4 and I was like right in
exchange for nudie pics and he was like
no I don't think he's signed on that's
great Jeff we had a great joke in high
Qatar all right well Tyler thank you
again for that ps4 dude haven't spoken
in a while you've kind of vanished just
like so many people who give me things
that's what my dad would do by me would
love and I love him for it